we're at a tipping point in human
history a species poised between gaining
the stars and losing the planet we call
home even in just the past few years
we've greatly expanded our knowledge of
how earth fits within the context of our
universe NASA's Kepler mission has
discovered thousands of potential
planets around other stars indicating
that earth is but one of billions of
planets in our galaxy Kepler is a space
telescope that measures the subtle
dimming of stars as planets pass in
front of them blocking just a little bit
of that light from reaching us Kepler's
data reveals planets sizes as well as
their distance from their parent star
together this helps us understand
whether these planets are small and
rocky like the terrestrial planets in
our own solar system and also how much
light they receive from their parent Sun
in turn this provides clues as to
whether these planets that we discover
might be habitable or not unfortunately
at the same time as we're discovering
this treasure trove of potentially
habitable worlds our own planet is
sagging under the weight of humanity
2014 was the hottest year on record
glaciers and sea ice that have been with
us for millennia are now disappearing in
a matter of decades these planetary
scale environmental changes that we have
set in motion are rapidly outpacing our
ability to alter their course but I'm
not a climate scientist I'm an
astronomer I study planetary
habitability as influenced by stars with
the hopes of finding the places in the
universe where we might discover life
beyond our own planet you could say that
I look for choice alien real estate now
as somebody who is deeply embedded in
the search for life in the universe I
can tell you that the more you look for
planets like Earth the more you
appreciate our own planet itself each
one of these new worlds invites a
comparison between the newly discovered
planet and the planets we know best
those of our own solar system consider
our neighbor Mars Mars is small and
rocky and though it's a bit far from the
son it might be considered a potentially
habitable world if found by a mission
like Kepler indeed it's possible that
Mars was habitable in the past and in
part this is why we study Mars so much
our Rovers like curiosity crawl across
its surface scratching for clues as to
the origins of life as we know it
orbiters like the maven mission sample
the Martian atmosphere trying to
understand how Mars might have lost its
past habitability private spaceflight
companies now offer not just a short
trip to near space but the tantalizing
possibility of living our lives on Mars
but though these Martian vistas resemble
the deserts of our own homeworld places
that are tied in our imagination to
ideas about pioneering and frontiers
compared to Earth Mars is a pretty
terrible place to live
consider the extent to which we have not
colonized the deserts of our own planet
places that are lush by comparison with
Mars even in the driest highest places
on earth the air is sweet and thick with
oxygen exhaled from thousands of miles
away by our rain forests I worry I worry
that this excitement about colonizing
Mars and other planets carries with it a
long dark shadow the implication and
belief by some that Mars will be there
to save us from the self-inflicted
destruction of the only truly habitable
planet we know of the earth as much as I
love interplanetary exploration I deeply
disagree with this idea there are many
excellent reasons to go to Mars but for
anyone to tell you that Mars will be
there to back up humanity is like the
captain of the Titanic telling you that
the real party is happening later on the
lifeboats
thank you but the goals of
interplanetary exploration and planetary
preservation are not opposed to one
another no they're in fact two sides of
the same goal to understand preserve and
improve life into the future the extreme
environments of our own world are alien
vistas they're just closer to home if we
can understand how to create and
maintain habitable spaces out of hostile
inhospitable spaces here on earth
perhaps we can meet the needs of both
preserving our own environment and
moving beyond it I leave you with a
final thought experiment Fermi's paradox
many years ago the physicist Enrico
Fermi asked that given the fact that our
universe has been around for a very long
time and we expect that there are many
planets within it we should have found
evidence for alien life by now so where
are they well one possible solution to
Fermi's paradox is that as civilizations
become technologically advanced enough
to consider living amongst the stars
they lose sight of how important it is
to safeguard the home worlds that
fostered that advancement to begin with
it is hubris to believe that
interplanetary colonization alone will
save us from ourselves but planetary
preservation and interplanetary
exploration can work together if we
truly believe in our ability to bend the
hostile environments of Mars for human
habitation then we should be able to
surmount the far easier task of
preserving the habitability of the earth
thank you